[Music]
let's go to nolan in the opposite of
texas texas alberta canada what's up
nolan how we doing
hello what's up nolan
hey thanks for taking my call of course
brother thanks for calling what's up
um so my mom is getting remarried this
may okay
and i'm not sure how i should be
handling this because
i want to be happy for her
but the situation's kind of bothering me
so tell me about it
um so my
parents separated almost 11 years ago
okay
and i was
12 at the time
and i'm 23 now
and my mom has been with this guy
for three years
and uh prior to that she was single for
seven years
and um
now she's going to be marrying this guy
and he's a really nice guy but
i've come to realize that this is kind
of the peak of
my parents never getting back together
ah
so that um that's a common
common story that kids tell themselves
is it may work out again especially as
there's a little bit of space between
the divorce um the actual pain of the
divorce and not the pain the pain goes
forever that the the
proceedings of the divorce
and then parents start being more civil
and they even become friends again
and there's always this running
narrative that maybe they're going to
get back together
oh man that's hard so sounds like your
mom was single
stayed single long enough for her to be
able to dote on you until you left the
house is that about right
yeah that is correct wow what a what a
noble woman loneliness is brutal it is
brutal um tell me about your
relationship with your dad
um my relationship with my dad is
we're kind of close in some areas but we
don't have deep conversations together
okay how come
um
uh well we've never been able to kind of
form that that bond after the separation
why'd they get separated why they get
divorced
uh so my dad he had an affair
um with somebody that i knew
and your mom said i'm out
uh well my dad it was my dad's choice to
leave because he was had his eyes on
this other woman instead of my mom
are they still together
um
no my dad is not together with that
woman
but he has somebody else now
and they are engaged okay
oh man
um i don't know if anyone's ever told
you this they probably have and i don't
know if you believed them
that divorce wasn't your fault nolan
you believe me when i say that
yeah
many people have told me that and
i i want to believe it but sometimes
it's hard i know
and there's a 12 year old in there
that's still trying to figure out what
in the world you did to split them up
and i hate that for you yeah because it
wasn't on you
and there's part of you wondering with
everybody you date and everybody you go
out with when's it gonna come when are
they gonna leave you
and every time you get close to somebody
who's a
male role model you keep wondering when
they're going to leave whether it's a
boss or a supervisor or coach or
something like that
and
it's hard to trust your parents even
though you love them
and so you've just kind of been
untethered and the story's been the
thing that's held you together and now
the story is for sure haven't appeared
at the end of it right and this whole
thing's hard yeah
brother what's not your fault
and i hate this for you
i hate this hate this hate this and
divorce is so common
that
we forget how devastating it is
man i hate this for you brother
so the real challenge here is how to own
the past right
how do you own what happened how do you
make sense of what happened and then how
do you get on to what comes next
and so the question i'll ask you is
while you're healing and while you're
starting to write something new
what do you want tomorrow to look like
man because this has haunted you for
half your life
yeah i just
i just want to make the most of my life
and
not repeat the cycle okay so
uh that's real like highfalutin language
i want to make the most of it what does
that actually mean
um
i think i just want to
honor my parents and
and you know love them and not
not judge them for for their past things
and all that and i want to have a good
relationship with my family okay
and
i just want to
i want to be successful in whatever i do
in my life okay
here's what's so hard about divorce
is
you plugged into that relationship and
that relationship unplugged from you
and if one of your goals is to have
great relationships with your family
that's noble and the idea is great but
it takes two to have a relationship
and
you can spend tons of energy and
passion and excitement and
all that stuff trying to make
relationships work with people who are
not interested in having relationships
with you
this is gonna be hard for me to hear to
tell you i don't mean to bag on your old
man
but it's his job to connect with you
he's your dad
and he chose not to
and that sucks
the reason you don't have deep
conversations with your dad is that he's
never had them with you
you're his kid
it's his job to set up an environment
where you feel safe enough to talk to
him where you feel safe enough to
challenge him to ask him hard questions
to push him on things him to push you on
things him to ask you hard questions him
to call you and say what are you doing
why are you wearing that
those are only
true and noble and accountable
conversations if there's a relational
context and most kids go their whole
life asking themselves what did i do
to my dad that was so bad that he
couldn't give me that
and that's why it's so important from
you to hear me say that wasn't on you
man
and you've got to make peace with the
fact that that that relationship may
never happen because of him
because he chose for it not to be
you still respect him you still honor
him you don't talk crap about him you
move on with your life
but at some point you have to stop
beating yourself up over a relationship
that wasn't yours to hold on to it was
his
do you believe me when i say that
yeah yeah i do believe that that's hard
i know it's hard
so let me paint you a picture of what
the other side of this can look like
your father dishonored your mom
and then instead of
healing that dishonor
he bolted he left
he took off on her
left her high and dry alone he left you
you got brothers and sisters
yeah i have two younger brothers yeah he
bailed on his three boys
and mom duct tape that thing together
your mom's pretty awesome
yeah she's great yeah
she's probably not perfect that's hard
the the amount of loss and trauma and
then raising three knucklehead boys is
hard right i can only imagine that
um and then here she is
and so
if you can wrap your head around this
hard concept
your parents marriage is not a
reflection of you
them not getting back together is not
the signal that ultimately you failed
because you had nothing to do with their
relationship
you can be devastated you can be
heartbroken you can be
like pissed off all those things are
good
the whole things are right all those
things are noble
it's how you act on the back end of
those things and so
what your mom looks like is she took a
long route and she
doubled down on you guys and she finally
said i'm not going to be lonely anymore
and she found as you put him a great guy
a good guy
which is incredible
i would begin
honoring that
and hear me say this
the discomfort you have in honoring that
doesn't mean it's wrong
does it mean that it's um
that you're somehow you're gonna feel
like you're betraying your dad
i want you to put that nonsense down
you're not betraying your dad you're
loving your mom
and this guy who's going to take care of
your mom he's a good man sounds like
he's a good guy he is going to give your
mom peace and he's going to give your
mom connection and he better not cheat
on your mom right he's going to be the
guy that stepped in that gap that your
father left
and
here's what i would recommend you do and
if you've listened to the show i've said
a thousand times i would write your dad
a letter that you're never gonna send
him
and tell him everything
how heartbroken you are how hard you
tried
ask him why he never connected with you
ask him what was so bad about his son
that he left him
what's so bad about those little
brothers that he just took off on him
and then i want you to write your 12
year old self a letter
and say dear 12 year old me
remember the house you grew up in
remember that house remember the school
you were at
talk about some of those details to help
to bring that that memory back and then
i want you to let that kid off the hook
and say hey you've been fighting for me
for 12 years now
it's time for you to go play
it's time for you to go have fun
because you got dragged into an adult
fist fight and you were not prepared for
that fight
so when i say those things nolan like
how's that
does that ring true to you or does that
sound like hogwash
no that rings true for sure okay write
those two letters and then here's your
third letter okay it's your third
homework assignment
that letter to your dad may be three
paragraphs it may be 25 pages
okay
a letter to yourself maybe five
paragraphs it may be 25 pages let that
stuff go and you may want to talk to
that little boy a couple of times
because he's been fighting for you for a
long time
then the last letter i want you to write
that you're gonna actually send is to
your mom
and i want you to tell her how brave you
think she is how strong you think she is
that this new marriage is gonna be hard
but that you are in her corner and you
love her and you you're gonna try to
love this new guy and you're gonna
respect him
and that you're going to ask for her to
be graceful with you because the whole
thing is kind of weird but you are fully
in
you're in mama's corner just like she's
been in yours
i want you to wrap your head around that
write that letter and then actually send
that one but a big chunk of that is is
to thank your mom thank her for sticking
around when dad bailed thanks for
raising you three little crazy crazy
kids
for making sure you all had food and
clothes
and for never walking out on you
because mom took the hard path
does that sound good
yeah sounds good all right brother nolan
what we thinking about you man
hey in that letter with this make sure
your mom saves a dance for you at her
wedding
that way you don't have to say anything
y'all are just going to dance you're
going to hug
you're going to put your big old 23 year
head 23 year old head on her
little bitty shoulder
you all are going to dance like you
haven't danced in about 10 or 15 years
you're worth that dance she's worth that
dance